every week since 1869 Nature has brought
you the very latest and best scientific
developments over the years we've
evolved our journal to keep pace with
the changing environments of science and
publishing so today you can read nature
imprints online at nature calm on your
iPhone and on the iPad now we focused on
you the reader we've redesigned nature
in print and online based on your needs
everything inside the magazine is easier
to find with our new look table of
contents and color-coded sections we
know how busy you are so we've collected
the most important science stories up
front this week presents internationally
minded editorials alongside the most
important science stories of the last
seven days and a look ahead at next
week's news agenda we've added an
opinion column worldview is a timely
personal take on the news in the world
of science by thought leaders news and
focus dives deeper into the science
policy and funding issues that affect
you so as well as bringing you breaking
stories here are reporters analyzed
events to give you the stories behind
the news in comment you'll find opinions
book reviews and correspondence here you
can take in the wisdom of opinion
leaders and take part in the
conversation yourself original research
is the core of nature and we've
redesigned how we publish papers too
we've added easy to read summaries of
the latest papers published online our
popular news and views in which
scientists place the research in a wider
context have been moved to this section
so now they sit alongside the papers
themselves as you wanted at the back of
the magazine our careers pages give you
the best information and advice on
ground
university courses and industry trends
to help you make the most of your
scientific career we've redesigned
nature online as well you told us you
want quick and easy access to nature's
news stories research papers and careers
information so we put all these right on
the homepage you'll notice we've added a
top level menu to make the site easier
to navigate and we put in quick links to
our most popular content including the
award-winning nature podcast and our
manuscript submission page this new
carousel makes it easy to browse the
latest Daily News features and opinions
click on the research tab and you'll
find the latest papers organized by
subject taking you straight to the
research that matters to you this is the
new look nature however you read it in
print online or on the move via your
iPhone or iPad rediscover your nature